and there is dean cramer trying to turn
his season around one two
now swinging a ground ball off the right
side of the mound out to second urea is
playing up the middle throws to first
and springer set down
hammer deep center field mckenna racing
back and runs it down on the track
ryan mckenna covering some ground
blue jays down in the first no score and
they will face sunjin ryu for his 28th
start of the season he was so good as
last time out against the yankees six
innings three hits no run six strikeouts
2-1 fastball chopped out in front of the
plate hopping into the middle of the
diamond backhanded by simeon off balance
throw to first the stretch by vlady to
get the out oh what a play on both ends
marcus simeon deep at second base
ranging to his right at the cut of the
grass in the dirt on the shortstop side
of the bag with a fade away throw and
then the stretch by guerrero
now the orioles sent up a man at scoring
position and he'll send anthony
santander up to the plate he's going to
hit from the right side
pitch in
a fly ball left field deep guriel
looking back and this one is bleacher
bound midway up the bleachers santander
with a two-run homer off of hyunjin ryu
as the orioles back-to-back extra base
hits against the veteran lefty in a
two-nothing way to the first
16 home runs now for anthony santander
that one was 408 feet
left side gloved by gutierrez
fires and mancini
stays in contact with the bag for the
out wow a hot smash
gloved by gutierrez he's been fun to
watch ben how good has he been lurtis
had a couple of hits last night scored a
run in that wacky sixth inning one-two
bringing a drive get up bar get out of
here and gone
where does guriel jr with his 17th home
run and his 12th and 13th rbi against
the orioles this season and just like
that we're tied at two the average is on
the rise the home run total is on the
rise and that ball on the rise and gone
quickly
so marina is not running and it's called
strike three mckenna was on his way
toward first and he is called out on
strikes that's three strikeouts for ryu
a big chance here for the orioles with
second and third and only one out hit to
the right side that'll get a run in
play the first
and it's an rbi for richie martin on the
ground out he gets a shake of the hand
from his first base coach anthony
sanders and the orioles on top 3-2
austin didn't wait long last night to
extend his hit streak to 16 games he
tripled in the first inning high fly
ball left field and deep back on the
track it is gone
austin hayes continues his red-hot
hitting the hitting streak extended to
17 games
and the orioles are on top five to two
guerrero lined up to the right fielder
his first time up
right-handed batter in the pitch there's
a curveball launched in the air
straightaway center field mckenna
getting to the wall turning around he
leaps he can't get it it's gone
number 43 to straight away center field
for vladimir guerrero jr
it's an all too familiar trip around the
bases for vladi
runner at first one out payoff
hernandez swing and a miss kramer rings
him up on a fastball in his first
strikeout back in the bigs
02. dickerson chases kramer below the
zone on a change-up back-to-back
strikeouts for dean cramer
[Applause]
got him to swing and miss
that fastball up and away big out one
down
pace is loaded one down chance to break
it wide open here for the birds hammered
down the left field line extra bases
it's against the wall two runs are in
and they'll stop
at third base pedro severino two rbis
for ryan mckenna and the orioles
stretched the lead to 7-3 another
hard-hit ball
and the lead is up to four and another
really good approach kelvin gutierrez at
the plate the right he fires and the
pitch is stopped on a dive by but the
runners coming home here's the play at
the plate the tag by janssen and he's
out
severino was breaking on contact and a
great sprawling stop made by bo buchet
popped up and he threw to the plate and
jansen was ready for contact and he took
the brunt of it from severino rochette
with a dive to his right in the hole the
throw went to the plate on a bounce and
then jansen went chest to chest with
severino and he got spun out of the clay
one-on-one face runner for danny jansen
blue jays backstop is 0 for one
[Applause]
johnson drills this to left and it's
going to get out of here danny jansen
a line drive two-run home run and the
blue jays are fighting their way back
daddy jackson's third home run since
coming off the injured list as an
absolute rocket his eighth of the year
and all of a sudden the blue jays are
right back in business orioles have now
homered 48 times since the all-star
break 1-1
hayes turns launches out to left field
again back at the wall jumping it's into
the stands keep the challenge coin
austin hayes
back-to-back home runs for doc holcomb
on 9 11 and the orioles boost their lead
back 8 to five
high fly ball deep left field
way back it is gone ryan mount castle
move over eddie murray you've got some
company number 27 for ryan
second most ever by an oriole rookie and
the birds lead is now nine to five
severino two for two one down
and there's another shot through the
hole into center field
around third santander he will score
standing up and the orioles add another
run to go up ten to five wow severino's
three for three anthony santander a
three for three day
pedro severino has matched that with
three base hits of his own blue jays are
loaded with some powerful bats
ground ball back behind is going to go
through
the sheds in this score here comes tay
oscar he comes in to score and jake glam
has driven in to his second hit of the
afternoon
tyler wells on the hill a chance to get
his third major league save that'll
bring the time run to the plate and
lourdes curiel he's had a big night at
the plate
puts this one high into the air and
right is back and
off the wall
that's going to score one for sure to
oscar's around third his score and
guerrilla comes through once again an
opposite field rbi
single as he stays at first base
dickerson ends up at third
and now the tying runs her on base
there's a drive to right field
dickerson is tagging at third he'll come
in to score
but now there are two outs
check that that's the first down of the
inning you know in there
so george springer will come to the
plate with the man at first and two out
springer singled sharply to right field
his last time up
[Applause]
swinging it drive left field stay fair
ball stay fair ball it's gone
george springer has given the blue jays
the lead with a two out two run home run
unbelievable
the blue jays the never say die blue
jays that i am not going to give away
any at bat blue jays come storming back
to take the lead
with a four spot here in the seventh
inning he has saved 16 of 17 attempts 16
straight
the 3-1
fastball fouled back
or will it stay playable
running over from third underneath that
lamb will have a play just beyond the
camera well that ball just stayed
playable and the 1-2 pitch
fastball hit in the air out to deep
center field dyson racing to his left in
front of the wall reaches out and he
makes the catch
gerard dice it again
ground ball shaving will get it and
that's the ball game jordan romano picks
up his 17th save of the season george
springer with another big home run a two
out two run home run at the top of the
seventh and nate pearson picks up the
win contributions from everybody up and
down the order
you